hello how are you greetings at 3 gonzález
with an informative hat for today
wednesday july 28 an officer of the
nevada roads and highways community is in critical condition
after a police chase
on interstate 15 this happened
yesterday afternoon when the  agents were trying to
stop a suspect for car theft who
ended up being hit at the end of the
chase the suspect was shot and
killed
and nevada returns to the rule of
mandatory use of masks to reduce
the spread of coronavirus in the state
this new rule begins on friday  in
the morning the
clark county school district says masks
must be worn by all students and staff
both in buildings
and on buses there are exceptions
for those with a medical condition
today nevada governor styps and
solar will speak on evictions in the
state the moratorium on evictions expires
on sunday and that is why the
govt  ernador will discuss measures and resources
to prevent mass evictions the
conference begins at 4 in the afternoon
now we move on to the weather forecast
we will have sunny skies accompanied
by dry weather with temperatures
reaching 103 degrees we will not have
drizzle in the valley for at least one
day or  Two, since they will possibly return
on Thursday night, there is a
chance of rain for Friday
and Saturday. Have a nice day. I am
Andrés González and this was about the
Indies Now news program in Spanish.